And there's so much clickbait out there
because it's such an effective way to
get people to pay attention to
things because it's, as you said,
people focus on failure and negative
and anger. That's who we want to see.
Controversy. That's what we want to see.
People would want to see the anger and,
and you know, why do you think that
is? Because it's just the times.
It's, it's, that's what's
cool. Now, is that what it is?
The coolest being negative.
You know how you always have
some people is a great example.
How you have people who mean you
can talk about a movie. All right.
We didn't talk about
titanic. Wow. And Titanic,
one of the biggest movies of all
time. Fucking great movie. He'll, yes,
it was great movie. And why guy for
no reason to go. I fucking hated it.
Why? Yeah, like titanic.
Fucking bullshit. Why Manga?
The odd Noah.
Now tell me why.
Why did you hate it that
Tom told you about that?
The cool thing is just being different.
I wanna I want to be completely
opposite than all even true positive.
You know what? Nah, Nah,
Nah. That shit was ass. Wow.
Wow.
Why was it as you have people that just
like to do that? Oh yeah, for sure. And,
and what happens when one person does it?
Another person for no reason. I'll go.
Yeah, me too. Yeah, that shit was
ass, man. I, I ain't like it either.
Did you see it?
Which I'll talk about.
You don't have to know
what they're talking about,
but you just want to hop on the negative
train because that's what's cool.
It's not cool to be positive.
It's not cool to be happy.
I don't know if it's a cool thing.
I think it's usually people
that are really frustrated
with their lives. 100% of,
what's the, that's the factual side to
it. I did a joke before, it was like,
do you think Michael Jordan leaves
Youtube comments? Like, I bet he does now.
That's awful winters. No, not at all.
Type of people that want to get mad and
complain constantly about shit like that.
Do you know what it takes
to do this right here?
Right here. I'll tell you how I feel
right in your comments section. Joe Rogan,
you can kiss my ass.
You know what that takes you or what do
you have going on that you have the time
to just simply be that negative and
do it in this world and it's just a
mismanagement of your time.
Time is so valuable and I don't think
people understand how valuable they can be
if they use their time correctly. Yeah.
Yes. Now, have you always been like this?
If you always put this fucking
guy, man, but always, always.
Really.
I find a light in every dark tunnel.
I will find a goddamn
light, man. I hear it all.
You'd listen when I tell you to wait
on my back is so heavy of all the stuff
that I deal with and I'm fine.
The reason why I'm fine is
because I'm genuinely happy.
I'm happy and I'm not happy
just because of the success.
The success x is a bonus.
I'm happy because I truly know the
definition and the feeling that comes with
happiness. I truly know it. I felt it.
I felt it when I said, Yo,
what really makes me happy?
And I look at heaven and Hendrickson, I
look Hizo. I look at my wife, I go, Yo,
I didn't have the family shit when
I was coming up. Y'All got one.
I got one. Look, what I
done did, look what I built.
These people depend on me. I provide
for these people. That makes me happy.
That makes me happy. When my daughter
comes up, dad, you're not only my dad,
you're my best friend. Yo,
I'm happy. That's my world.
So everything else from the outside
that comes in, you're, you're,
you're throwing shit at a, at a,
at a bubble that can't be popped.
There's a force field around me.
There's a force field around
me because what matters,
what really matters
loves me whole heartedly.
And when you had that and you
understand that you're unbreakable,
so if you don't add to that force field,
if you don't make my force field
stronger, you don't, you don't,
you don't get time from me.
My team hartbeat productions,
the people underneath my umbrella.
You're a part of my force field.
You believe what I believe
we all see the same things.
We want the same things.
So we march with the same beat.
You can't,
you can't shake that.
We are an individual that seen that and
understands that if you've never felt
that, if you have no idea what that
feels like and it's easy to shake you.
That's why some people are easily broken.
Being broken is not a hard thing.
It's not a hard thing.
So those that do get broken, those that
do get down, those that do get depressed.
I understand, I understand. I don't,
I don't knock people for it. Mm.
I don't knock anybody for it.
What I also understand is
that the encouragement that
can come from so many can
add value for those that
may need a little push,
that may need a little amen.
Picky Chyna.
It's so easy to be that positive
reinforcement for somebody and add value.
It's so easy. But some people choose to
throw that aside and kick while your dad.
Mm.
I try to put out the light of positivity
because whoever's out there you,
I don't know what it could
do for somebody else,
but somebody else may just simply
look at him and say, Yo, to wait.
He embraces his kids. It makes me
want to be a better father. Yoda,
where did this man doesn't stop in a
way that every day he wakes up and he's
just positive,
regardless of what's going on,
makes me realize that this shit ain't
so bad the way he gets up and says, Hey,
today's another day. It's a morning. Let's
all be better than we were yesterday.
Somebody probably needed to hear that.
The more that I can give that out and
I can take my platform to throw good
energy out,
I'm doing my part because there's so
many that thought the complete opposite.
Yeah. I don't want to be a part of that.
That's beautiful man, and that's true.
I believe you. It's not, it's
not forced. It's not phony. Yeah.
It's not fake.
That shit every day I hear shit every day.
It's very contagious too.
I had a lady, I lady, right?
Lady rolled down a window.
She goes,
where are you going to
make a good movie again?
I said, did you see the upside? I
thought the upside was good. What's that?
Oh Shit. Some movie. It's one of
my movies that's out us think.
I think it's a good movie.
I didn't see that.
All right, ma'am. You have a beautiful
day. That's, yeah. All right.
That's it.
With such conviction, like literally
I could have said a lot of shit.
Like she rolled her window down.
You could tell she still had the crank.
I got to set a lot of shit
girls. A lot of things that
I can say to you, ma'am,
where are you going to make a good movie?
It's snapping
that one out. The upside. You see
the other side? What's that? Oh,
it's a movie out now. Amazing that
that's how she chose to come out here.
I see it. I get it. She chooses
to come at you with a negative.
I get it every day when you won't be
funny again and I'm trying my best,
trying my best. If it's not working
for you, hopefully I do better soon.
What do you, what do you, what am
I going to feed into that and why?
Why, why, why? For what?
For what?
It seems to have been working thus far.
Are you getting this positive attitude
towards life from life experience?
Are you getting it from books?
Did someone teach you how to find this?
I'm getting it from the
experiences and from the,
the real understanding of
perfection doesn't exist.
Don't exist.
Yo know we're in a time right now
where people expect perfection.
You expect perfection and I
don't know where this came from.
I don't know what happened.
That this is the criteria for living.
My true understanding is, all right,
you got one life and that one life.
The goal for us is to live it to the
best of our ability from the beginning to
what said the n in the middle
and the beginning. Middle.
You're going to do things. You're going
to make mistakes. You're going to fuck up.
You're supposed to learn and then move
forward with the understanding of what
not to do and when you move forward.
Live may get better, it may not,
but somewhere along the lines is going
to click and everything that went through
back here was supposed to happen
so that now that I'm here,
I'm able to go ahead with such a high
level of knowledge and I can make other
people better. I can make myself
better. I could do more from a family.
Something happens.
My Dad is the prime example,
crazy drug addict and I'm out of jail.
Life was very bad,
very fucking bad for my dead son,
got successful son,
then took money,
gave it to his day. Here's
your house, here's your truck.
Here's your monthly. At this age,
I want you to live your life.
You may have mistakes. You can't rebuild
and correct the things you've done.
I'm your son. I love you. You
can't go back in and Redo.
You can't try to keep going backwards
and about me. You got grandkids.
Go be the best grandpop you can be for
these grandkids. That's your focus now.
Where's this energy devoted to
being a grandpa for the grandkids?
Don't worry about me,
but something happened in your life.
Something happened that took you into the
direction to reap the benefits of your
son's happiness and success.
My energy is now contagious is
enough and I hand it to you,
so now you're able to give that off to
all these other people that you're around.
Something happens and that's an every
single life in every life I under stand
that there's a payoff for bad
eventually cause a pay off.
It can't be bad,
but for so long,
if you got the strength and
the understanding to realize
that shit will change,
it will change. It's impossible.
It's just like poker.
I don't know if you play poker
nut, I don't. You play poker.
You can run bad forever,
but it will eventually turn around.
Once you grasp the
understanding of the game,
eventually it's going to
turn around blackjack.
You're never going to be at the casino,
but eventually you're going to have
a good run. If you catch a run,
you'll do good.
Get the fuck out of there.
You waited long enough for it
to happen here, come catch it.
Leave anything in life
will eventually tie. Good.
Now.